Good morning John. It is the 11th annual Project for Awesome,
and that means that I'm here to tell you about why solving hard problems is so hard.
There's a bit of a universal law in logistics that the last little bit of
transport that an item has to do to get to its destination is by far the most difficult leg of the journey.
This is true in telecommunications. It's also true in, like, your circulatory system.
It's called the last mile problem.
Weirdly enough, it takes almost as much energy and work to get, like, something that I ordered off Amazon—say, this—
from like China where it's manufactured
all the way to, like, the distribution warehouse in Missoula, Montana
as it does to get it from the distribution warehouse in Missoula to my house.
This is a very squeaky prop.
So what's going on here?
The moment this thing is manufactured in China it has like one place to go to.
It goes to its port and then from there - from that port it can go to, like, maybe a dozen or so other ports in the world.
Then when it arrives at whatever port gets to, it has maybe a few thousand different warehouses
or stores that could end up in.
If it ends up in a store it has to wait for a
person to go there and buy it, but if it's being shipped directly to the person, directly to me
then it ends up in this centralized local warehouse with tens of thousands of other products,
and those tens of thousands of products have to
go to potentially hundreds of thousands of different individual places.
For 99% of this thing's travels it could have gone to like one of a few thousand different places
and that last 1%,
it's gonna go to one of literally hundreds of millions of places.
The last mile problem is kind of why oftentimes when we have really big ideas about how to fix things,
those ideas don't work.
Because when you get to the last mile your one overarching solution to all problems
becomes tens of thousands or hundreds of thousands of different solutions
that are all hard to work out.
And that's all work, like hard work.
And when it comes to delivering health care or water or food in parts of the world where those things aren't available,
it used to be work that just didn't get done.
But now people are doing it. Organizations like Save the Children and Last Mile Health.
And they solve the last mile problem for health care the only way you can solve it:
with problem-solvers.
They work with and train and employ people from those communities
to become community health care workers.
Those people then help to grow the economy, to educate other people, and to keep their communities,
and thus the entire global community, more healthy.
So this costs money.
But let me venture that maybe this is one of the best things
we could possibly be spending money on as a society.
But what if in addition to helping fund that very cool work of solving that very hard problem,
you also get cool stuff!
Well, that's why you should go to projectforawesome.com/donate
where for the first part of the Project For Awesome, all of the money
up to seven hundred thousand dollars will be matched.
And all that money raised in the first half will be split between Last Mile Health and Save the Children.
Stuff you can get: smashed pennies, commemorative coin,
digital download bundle with a bunch of different real cool stuff
and including outtakes scenes from "Turtles All The Way Down".
We've got socks and bandanas
and I'm painting a bunch of...rocks??
Lots of stuff. Some of it's already sold out, some of it is well on its way to selling out,
including the Project For Awesome charity calendar,
which I just happen to have on the floor right here!
It includes this photo of me
being splashed in the face by champagne.
No, it is not photoshopped and yes, I do know what it's like to have champagne on the inside of your sinuses.
During the second half of the Project For Awesome,
all of the money raised will be split among charities voted on by the community.
And the way this works is people will make videos promoting their favorite charities
and if you like those videos and you like those charities you can vote on them at projectforawesome.com.
The charities that get the most votes will get a
portion of the money that we raised in the second half the Project For Awesome.
Also the 48 hour charity livestream is going on right now,
you could check it out at projectforawesome.com/live.
You can also probably just find it on the vlogbrothers channel.
We'll be having a lot of fun and doing a lot of weird stuff and I really want you to join us.
And if you want to make yourself happy,
both with cool things that you can have access to or have shipped to your house,
and with the knowledge that you are helping
solve some of the hardest problems that humanity has left to solve,
you can go to projectforawesome.com/donate.
John, I will see you in the livestream.